The joe rogan experience.
And I think a lot of it comes down to
that we shouldn't sort of protest what
we shouldn't agree with,
but we should build the things we should
build a future that we do agree with.
Um,
so when you look at the past few hundred
years of modernity and,
and our civilization,
what we see is dramatic positive trends
in terms of health,
wealth,
education,
violence,
and we had steven pinker on your show,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
so I think that's really,
um,
yeah,
really positive trends and we've done a
good job in that and that all comes down
to,
uh,
our ability to sort of imagine things
that don't exist yet.
So sort of technology and innovation and
being able to work,
uh,
work together in an effective way,
which is think about the corporation.
Um,
so,
so I think those have been,
um,
yeah,
sort of very good trends.
And I think what we should do is we
should also think about how to apply
those to the area outside of our own
species and to the rest of the
environment.
Because when you look at all those
positive trends over the past few
hundred years,
um,
and then,
yeah,
that's all good,
but there's one very big exception,
which is the impact to the environment.
It's almost like we've had all the
success at the cost of the environment
and,
but I think that instead of it or some
people that have sort of a more
reactionary feel to this and they said,
well,
um,
look at,
uh,
all these problems,
it was created by businesses and by
technology.
So we should stay as far away from those
things as possible.
And I think that's sort of,
um,
you know,
that's sort of stupid.
I think that,
um,
it really just shows that these are
very,
um,
powerful ways of getting things done.
And I think a much more effective way
was to sort of apply that,
what has worked in other areas and then
also apply that to the area of the
environment.
So,
so I don't think,
you know,
I,
for example,
think that the car problem is not going
to be solved by banning cars,
I think is going to be sold by electric
cars.
And I don't think the meat pollution
problem is going to be solved by
everyone becoming Vegan.
I think it's going to be solved by
things like lab grown meat and other
kinds of alternatives.
Um,
so,
and that's why I also think that,
um,
yeah,
the ocean cleanup or the plastic
pollution problem is not going to be
solved by sort of people trying to do
their own little bits and um,
you know,
trying to live without plastic or things
like that I think is going to be solved
by,
um,
you know,
things like,
uh,
plastics that do not harm to the
environment as well as technologies like
the ocean cleanup to sort of clean up
after herself.
So,
um,
yeah.
And I hope that the education can be a
sort of a,
as a symbol of that approach.
You had like one of the most spectacular
fights with Jon Jones.
I mean,
down to the wire is as close as it gets.
And when you get out of a fight like
that,
will,
you almost won the title against the
greatest of all time.
Like,
what is,
what is that feeling like and where do
you go from there?
Uh,
you know,
it was tough.
It was really tough because I know
everybody was saying,
are you winning this fight?
Winning this fight?
You have to be run this against him.
Are you winning this fight?
I,
if it felt like,
and like you said,
it was something,
it was just,
it was just right there at the goal
line.
You know,
I didn't really pass that goal nine at
all.
Um,
I just felt like that it was tough.
It was tough,
but by,
but like now I'm sitting here now
talking to you.
It's a big,
it's a really good experience for me.
And,
and in,
I really,
it's a good time for me.
If I was,
w is a highlight in my career for sure
in my life,
for sure.
It was such a close fight when the,
when the scorecards are being tagged and
you,
uh,
you know,
you're just sitting there waiting for
the decision.
Did you think you hadn't,
you know,
I didn't know.
Right?
I didn't know much chaos.
Could you even remember what had
happened over the last five rounds?
I remember,
I remember the,
I remember the fight,
uh,
and I got,
I remember almost the whole fight,
but it was just John.
John's just such a basis.
He,
I'm telling you,
just for me,
John Jealous winning over John Jones is
bigger than taking the belt.
I'm telling him,
that guy's the guy is such a beast and,
and uh,
yeah.
What was the question?
No,
it's okay to express yourself.
That's fine.
I mean,
I agree with you.
He is a beast.
We had a little chalkboard sign out
front that said Venison is the new Kale
and you know,
we get cute with our sign.
We tease other restaurants around us
like we have fun with the sign and it's
fun.
And uh,
the cyclist Vegan rode by and took huge
offense to our sign and all of a sudden
one day these protesters just showed up.
So,
um,
originally I was just kind of frustrated
because they're totally misguided
because,
um,
we take a lot of pride in where our food
comes from.
We have Vegan and vegetarian dishes on
the menu.
Uh,
and I really respect that type of diet.
So we were just totally floored with why
this was happening.
And,
um,
so this started to go on.
They'd started come every week and they
went from like two or three people being
kind of peaceful to being like 10,
15 people,
not so peaceful.
So,
uh,
it's when it turned not so peaceful.
They were shouting at our,
at our guests and shouting in our door
and really trying to harm our business.
That,
uh,
I just kind of got fed up.
Last resort went down,
we get a hold dear a couple times a
month and we,
we butchered ourselves.
And,
uh,
I just said,
screw it.
Screw it.
I'm like,
I'm going to get these people to get out
of here.
So I thought that that would make them
go away.
How did you think that was gonna make
it,
make
them go away and not escalate it?
Uh,
I don't know.
I was,
it was just totally like last resort,
a totally fed up.
Um,
I wanted to defend myself,
defend our customers.
You know,
you could see people walking in visibly
upset,
um,
you know,
they're being shouted at being screamed
at,
called a murderer as they're walking in
for dinner and like,
you're going on a date,
you want to hear this time and then
people are screaming at you,
uh,
you know,
just for eating.
So,
uh,
I was just fed up and I just kinda
thought like,
you know,
buzz off and why?
So just one sign once I seen is the new
Kale one sign set this whole thing off.
Yeah.
I had those abilities.
If I'm a kid growing up in this
environment and I can't find refuge in
my school,
I can't find refuge at home because my
mom's working three or four or five
jobs.
So she's never there.
Where am I going to go find parents?
I'm go,
where am I going to find that pyramid to
influence?
I'm gonna find on the streets.
So now I'm on the streets being led by
people who grew up in exam tech
conditions that I grew up in.
And so now I'm like,
okay,
well I have to make money.
What am I going to do for money?
While then there's their knock old
economy very conveniently,
right?
Therefore me,
Sell drugs.
So now I'm selling,
now I'm standing on the corner selling
drugs.
I got to protect my product,
right?
If I don't,
someone's gonna take it from me.
So what do I do?
I get a gun,
I carry a gun.
Now I'm stuck in this situation.
Now I'm just stuck in this violent loop,
right?
If that feeds on itself.
And so now I'm stuck defending myself
against the guy who's shooting at me,
trying to take my stuff and I'm shooting
back in him.
Maybe not because I'm trying to take
care of stuff,
but because he's trying to take them on,
right?
So that's where you get that violence
that comes from that,
from those particular areas.
Now,
if we would've sat back and said,
okay,
we have hyper concentrated areas in this
country.
This is a widespread,
it's hyper concentrated communities in
this country that are dealing with this,
that are also the result of the vast
majority of our gun violence.
And we sat back and thought about it
from a socioeconomic standpoint.
How do we fix this?
What do we do?
How do we present opportunity?
I'm not saying going in and just hand
out stuff,
but how do we fix this from the
standpoint of improving our schools?
How was I can drive five minutes,
one direction and have a school that has
everything you can name and then driving
and the driving the opposite direction
the school has can barely have textbooks
to give to their kids.
Think about that.
So why,
why aren't we focusing our energy on
building that up versus talking about,
oh we need to get the guns off the
streets.
You did that.
You have that in Chicago.
You have every gun law imaginable in
Chicago,
but yet southside Chicago still looks
the way that it does still has a
violence that it does,
right?
So if we would,
if we provide,
when you give people something lose or
the lift for,
they don't throw away life so easily.
Plain and simple.
So if my social economic status is in
the dirt,
I don't have a problem looking at
another kid down the street and shooting
at him and taking his life.
I don't have anything.
I don't have anything to lose,
but if we would focus our attention in
fixing,
same way we talk about the mental health
issue with respective mass shootings and
school shootings,
we wouldn't have to worry about the guns
because we won't have people wanting to
do those things or have the capability
to do those things.
Right.
So then that deals with that vast
majority of the violence that we had.
They're focusing that energy in fixing
those communities.
The point of the story was this,
Isis came around and people were
suddenly like,
oh my God,
where did this come from?
Of course,
those of us who had been monitoring the
situation knew this was going to come
back around very,
very heavy.
Now that isis has been pushed back.
And this is where this story is sort of
the point of the story is we've got to
resist the temptation to believe the
problem has been solved because the,
the organization known as Isis,
which isn't a bureaucracy has been
fought back,
but the ideology upon which that
organization was built,
um,
is still very much alive and it's still
strong.
Um,
what al Qaeda did while the whole world
was focused on Isis was exploit that
opportunity to rebuild and regroup and
they'd been rebuilding in Syria.
Now they are stronger than they have
ever been even under binladin because
for the first time in the history of
that organization,
they are firmly embedded within the
Syrian population as a genuinely kind of
viewed by the people that they were
fighting on behalf of as a grassroots
resistance organization.
Where's it before that,
they were seen as a terrorist group that
was like a,
you know,
just like a vanguard.
They've embedded themselves in the
Syrian population,
in the Yemeni,
uh,
civil war.
They've embedded themselves in north
Africa,
east Africa,
and in Pakistan.
And they are resurgent and they are
grooming a Hamza bin Laden who was been
not in Sun.
Um,
and the grooming him for leadership and,
and as an a time will come maybe in a
couple of months,
maybe in a couple of years where they
announced Hamza bin Laden as a new
leader of al Qaeda currently at Saint
Monzo.
Ari,
when they do that,
once they grooming has been complete and
assuming Hamza isn't killed,
uh,
up until then,
all of the fragments of what remains of
Isis will probably rejoin al Qaeda under
Hamza bin Laden.
And you'll have a stronger than ever
before Al Queida Organization.
And we've got to,
we've got to remember that we never
expected isis to emerge.
Hokkaido.
We'll come back with a vengeance.
Okay.